I'm Nicholas Katzenbach and I'm a
retired attorney I'm originally from New
Jersey from Trenton New Jersey where my
father was a practicing lawyer and
one-time Attorney General of New Jersey
and where his uncle was a prominent
Democrat my uncle was a prominent
Democrat who ran for governor once and
lost the next time he went to the
Democratic convention he lost to it up
start by the name of Woodrow Wilson my
father died when I was 12 years old and
it's hard to know whether I was always
interested in government and I really
would like to have had elective office
but where I came from in New Jersey in
that congressional district if you
weren't an Irish Catholic he didn't have
a chance growing up I think the people
were the most influence on it probably
with my mother certainly and there were
former partners of my father and there
were teachers at school some summit
school that were heavily influenced me I
think and others that probably
influenced me some it's hard to know the
influences that that that you had I my
mother was active in New Jersey she was
president of the State Board of
Education for some 30 years and so I was
interested in education I was interested
in public service and I think I got
probably most of that from my mother I
think they're probably several reasons
why I decided to write the book one I
was just bored and I needed to do
something to occupy my time and the
second reason was I was very distressed
by the present administration had bit
more than anything else what they were
do
to the Constitution and to the Justice
Department in terms of politicizing both
in ways that I thought were inconsistent
with our democracy as I had known it and
with our being what I've always thought
was the greatest country in the world
and I would hope would be the greatest
country in history but it has to
remember what it's doing and not succumb
to temptation well I think to tell the
truth my experience in World War two did
change considerably I left college in my
junior year early right after Pearl
Harbor attack and I left because I I
felt it just was important and it was
important for somebody who had a very
elite education as I did to simply join
the Armed Forces and not sit around and
think you should be intelligent sir
naval intelligence or something like
that to just do a job along with other
people and I I did and I volunteered the
villager to go overseas I wanted to go
overseas and I got shoved down on our
19th mission in North Africa and as we
crashed into the water I really said to
myself if I get out of this I'm going to
try to do something in this world not
make a fool of myself so I think the
experience was very big and very real
it never has played much of a role in my
life my father and my mother's and all
of her sisters we're very religious and
I was my father was religious all
members of the episcopal church and my
hometown of trenton and it just I'm not
anti religion I'm I don't think it just
has played a very important role in my
life I don't know whether I see that the
service mentality today or not we sure
had it in the 60s and one of the
wonderful things was the college
students pouring into the south to try
to register African Americans to vote in
really dangerous circumstances of course
three of them were killed doing that and
then in their protests of the Vietnam
War which which they may or may not have
understood and protests that continued
with the way south africans or what
white South African government was
treating blacks I don't see as much of
that today as I would like to see but
the experience is available to those who
will take it and it can be a wonderful
rewarding experience as I as I try my
best to paint in the book to say you're
working with other people to accomplish
something that you believe in there
can't be any greater thing than life
than doing them
look I'm old I'm a has-been all all that
I want to do is tell young people come
on this is your country take it on take
on the tough decisions they're the ones
that are fun they're the ones that take
a lot to decide you're not always going
to be successful you're going to make
mistakes but go on put your shoulder to
the wheel push I think the hardest
moments that I've had in my career we're
probably difficulties of finally getting
the 1964 Civil Rights Act through which
was a happy ending and things like I
described in the book the trial of Jim
Landis a fine person and yet we had to
do it it had to be done and Jim himself
knew it had to be done and said it had
to be done but prosecuting a fine man
for something that didn't amount to a
hill of beans is difficult and I think
disappointing and makes you unhappy but
you know we had failures not getting out
of Vietnam as a failure and I have often
wondered what I could have done and
didn't do so you have though though that
I think afterwards I had a very happy
career as IBM's chief legal officer I
enjoyed that tremendously I then decided
I solved all those problems and I better
not wait around there well they got some
others because I didn't have time to
some I was almost 65 so I decided to go
practice law in New Jersey and that was
probably a mistake I probably should
have stayed on and done that or done
tonight my whole career was not well
suited I think to practice
New Jersey oh I think in point of fact
actually I just hope my kids remember me
as a fair fair to middling father that's
about as much as I want